here on the show floor at the game
developers conference some things are
constant from gear to year you got your
boots of recruiters your purveyors of
middleware your awesome games at the IGF
but 2014 will be remembered as the year
of the VR headset big players like the
oculus rift and Sony's recently
announced Morpheus are joined by handful
of smaller operations in showing their
visions of the future of gaming but as
we are actually going to be the future
or would just be another one of these
peripheral fads that we've seen come and
go to gamespot editors have been
debating this very question and the
first one you're about to hear from mark
Walton isn't so optimistic he's got you
he's got to you again and he got me
behind oh my god I think I have to take
this helmet off I'm physically feeling
the spacer Kristen does anyone really
want virtual reality there's no denying
that it's an impressive potentially
game-changing piece of technology but
it's hard to see consumers abandoning
their TVs and strapping a display to
their face to play games it's all the
more troublesome for Sony's project
Morpheus which reeks of Sony hopping on
the VR bandwagon trying to chase down a
new and potentially lucrative audience
much like out it and Microsoft developed
motion technology following the success
of the we and we all know how that
turned out even with a supposedly
audience to tap into
and unlike the way for all the oculus
rift success with the developer
community and games media without a
release date there's still also no hard
evidence that it has wide appeal there's
the classic games peripheral problem to
consider two developers want a large
install base to sell to but consumers
are reluctant to buy into a new piece of
tech in large numbers without the games
to pack it up they've graphics engine
companies like epic games Crytek and
unity have all pledged support for
project Morpheus but as Nintendo found
out with the wii u third parties are
just as quick to abandon new platform as
they are to support it if it doesn't
live up to sales expectations both of
the big home console makers are hoping
to capitalize on V ours recent rebirth
but it is a hope and right now there's
little evidence to suggest that VR is
going to reach the kind of critical mass
that'll entice developers to create
games for it in the long term I'm just
hoping history isn't repeating itself
and we end up with a bunch of impressive
but for gossip peripherals but chase and
audience this simply wasn't there the
man has a point the history of video
games and the shelves of collectors are
all littered with gadgets and
peripherals that never caught on
attempts at vr have come and gone before
but this time Kickstarter successes and
widespread critical enthusiasm have some
people including Peter Brown believing
that VRS time has finally come while I
was playing the game it seems virtual
reality was playing a trick on my mind
the pictures and sounds around me were
all that was necessary to convince me I
was walking flying and fought
as an admirer of new and interesting
hardware I was immediately drawn to the
oculus rift when it was announced in
2012 but after a few tests I wasn't
convinced of the long-term success of
virtual reality when I played the port
of doom 3 and walked around a frozen
castle an epic games elemental demo on
the oculus both of these experiences
were mildly exciting but there was no
suspension of disbelief to be had apart
from motion blur related queasiness
nothing inside of me felt connected to
the experience before my eyes but fast
forward to august 2013 I'm at Gamescom
in cologne germany for an appointment
with CCP games to try out its new space
combat game Eve Valkyrie it had been
exactly a year since my first ripped
experience and with memories of motion
sickness still fresh in my mind I
suffered sweaty palms and nervous
thoughts as I made my way to the demo
booth little did I know that I was
walking into a demo that would forever
alter my opinion of VR and its potential
to change not only gaming but our
relationship with technology as a whole
unlike the other experiences i mentioned
Eve Valkyrie was built around the
limitations and aims of VR first the
notion of sitting in a cockpit of a
spacecraft translates perfectly to
sitting in a chair flying a jet doesn't
require you to turn your shoulders or
walk your torso and arms remain
stationary whether you're diving
climbing or turning most importantly
apart from controlling your perspective
within the cockpit you can lock on to
enemy spacecraft by following them with
your gaze I can't fully explain how
great it was to crane my neck backward
to lock on to a passing enemy ship but
it was an empowering feeling and I was
immersed in my role as a pilot not only
are your physical movements accounted
for in the virtual world but the
gameplay is enhanced as well after a few
minutes of dog fighting in space I began
to anticipate the effects of centripetal
force my brain had been tricked and my
fate as a VR evangelist took off having
witnessed firsthand the sort of
experience is that only VR can offer
I've seen that there's more to the
medium than I once thought the
experience allowed me to extrapolate the
potential that lies down the road at vr
hardware and software are continually
developed hand-in-hand in some ways the
industry is starting over from scratch
with VR and there are a lot of lessons
left to be learned as oculus is VP of
products Nate Mitchell likes to put it
vr is like a house of cards if you take
one card out such as the relationship
between physical and virtual movements
the illusion crumbles the fact is the
house of cards at present is just a
foundation but it's already attracting
lots of money and
the industry is in a much better
position to facilitate the dreams of
artists and designers than it was 20 or
30 years ago and with institutions like
USC successfully adopting VR for mental
health treatment the implications of the
tech outside of gaming will bolster its
legitimacy in the short term and spur
further funding and research in the long
term it's still the early days but with
the right experience under your belt I
think you'll agree that VR is the future
this time it's here to stay so is this
the dawn of the VR era in earnest there
are a lot of reasons to think so but how
much of that is just really really
really hoping that it's true i'm hopeful
myself and desperate to play that eval
curry demo that Peter was talking about
but what do you folks think is a healthy
skepticism necessary here or are you all
in on the VR future join me and your
fellow prognosticators in the comments
below as we discuss the very future of
the medium we all love so much did you
display the moment Ruth air are these
crude cartoon like characters that's not
the issue
you